Nhưng Xuân Cui Hà Tính vừa xong, là học sinh Xuân nhất ở chỗ á sẽ học bồm sấu tị của lại học mù nước,
Trung đại học trong tất nằm của Australia.
Phận học Xuân Cui Hà Tính, là học sinh của chỗ hật tương truyền Hà Tính,
trải qua nhiều khó khăn và át lực với tình thành nhật vết và sự nỗ lực,
Xuân Cui Hà Tính đã sản được sức học bộm của trong phần trung,
chỉ giá bà chăm sóng như nạn au đền, tương đương sấu tỷ đồng.
Đứng bình, Xuân Cui Hà Tính, phó kinh học sinh Xuân nhất của phục Xuân á,
Nhưng không bồng của đề học môn nhất hay không hành lịch tưu.
Chúc linh cho biết, hôm cạnh ra đình không khá ra,
nên sức phọt bồng này sức câu giảm bớt cánh nợt tay chính cho ra đình khi quyết định dù học.